machin avoir un petit bout sur votre
rôle vous jouez qui a alors cette pièce
est construite comme une à thriller
comme un suspense familiale alors il ya
une famille très puissante
la femme de cet auteur que toute la
thalie et on découvre au fur et à mesure
que cet auteur qui était soi disant un
espèce d'exemple un modèle de moralité
et 2 et 2,2 d'intégrité va pas du tout
il a fait une seconde vie et une seconde
vie magnifique parce que c'était avec
une femme absente
et cette autre femme dont le fils fait
la découverte au cours de la pièce elle
vivait aux états unis
elle vient se présenter un jour parce
que le jeune homme présente ses propres
écrits alors c'est formidable parce que
je suis un peu un fouteuse de merde je
sais qu'ils arrivent et qui bouleverse
l'ordre de cette famille mais qui en
réalité sauve cette famille parce que
c'est déjà avant l'heure une pièce sur
la transparence et je crois que ce bug
qui était très proche de fraudes
commençaient déjà à réfléchir à toutes
ces questions là que dans les familles
hier jour un secret de famille et est ce
que il est bon de le dévoiler ou pas
alors moi avec lui je pense qu'il est
toujours bon de dire la vérité que les
enfants peuvent supporter la vérité et
ils ne peuvent pas supporter l'opacité
du mensonge c'est ça qui vous plaît chez
se fait justement cet univers complexe 1
et alors il faut que vous vous rendez
compte que tout ça il a écrit ça dans
les années 20 même un peu plus tôt je
crois 19 ou toutes ces idées là et être
haineuse c'était vraiment un théâtre
d'avant-garde ou ont commencé à débattre
de la famille d'une autre façon sous
l'influencé évidemment de cette grande
découverte de freud sur les rapports
mère-fils père fille et et toutes ces
ambiguïtés
donc nous on joue ça aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que c'est
que c'est acquis mais pas du tout à
l'époque c'était tout à fait
révolutionnaire et je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il aurait connu à l'époque le succès
que nous allons comme la voit ici parce
que c'était très audacieux mais ce qu'il
ya de formidable sheets five c'est que
si jamais noir et blanc c'est très
subtil et je crois que le nouveau
théâtre nous devons restituer la
subtilité de l'existence
rien n'est tout à fait clair dans la vie
il faut pas dire que les gens sont bons
ou méchants juste ou injuste c'est
toujours plus plus ambigu et ça c'est la
grande richesse de zweig alors justement
je lisais dans une interview vous
concernant ça faisait longtemps qu'on ne
pas proposer quelque chose d'intéressant
alors écoutez je suis heureux d'avoir
refusé toutes les pièces que j'ai refusé
jusqu'à maintenant pour attendre celle
ci parce que je pense que chaque actrice
et chaque personne au théâtre trimballe
toutes les pièces qu'il a joué toutes
les choses qui l'a où on l'a vu et c'est
une très lourde responsabilité
il faut pas trahir l'espérance du public
le public m'a aimée d'un des choses
importantes j'ai un devoir vis-à-vis de
ses rôles importants
n'est ce pas j'ai joué arkadina dans la
mouette j'ai joué
le mari idéal j'ai joué une pièce
d'oscar wilde formidable qui
l'importance d'être constant
j'ai un devoir vis-à-vis de tous ces
grands rôles que j'ai joués et là c'est
la première fois depuis très longtemps
depuis plusieurs années que enfin j'ai
un rôle
disons à ma taille en tout cas à la
taille de l'ambition que j'ai parce que
pour une fois ce n'est pas crétin c'est
intéressant ça va même au delà de ça à
ça veut c'est ce qui d'ailleurs le
public on entend le public soupirait de
bonheur parce qu'on les emmène loin on
les emmène dans des grands sentiments
des choses nobles et des choses qui
d'ailleurs sont répréhensibles pas
toujours bien honnête et je pense que je
crois que les gens aient enfin deux sens
d'ailleurs deux pièces qui ont vraiment
s'attaque qu'à des grands sentiments
comment vous sentez sur scène ça fait
longtemps mais comment vous vous sentez
encore of chez moi moi sur scène vous
savez je n'ai pas je n'ai pas beaucoup
le trac mais j'ai pas le trac quand je
joue quelque chose de beau quand je joue
une pièce dont je suis amoureuse et dont
je sens que le public va va être
satisfaits ils vont quelque part me
remercier de de leur transmettre ça et
puis quand même le théâtre c'est notre
place c'est notre endroit nous les
acteurs
moi j'aime bien jouer avec tout mon
corps et comme on est en pied au théâtre
on n'est pas coupée en rondelles comme
au cinéma où tout d'un coup on prend ton
visage époux bien un morceau de ton
corps non là je joue avec toute ma
silhouette tout est et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que le public
choisi de regarder l'un ou l'autre et
quelquefois voit des choses très très en
détail
moi j'en oublierais jamais une fois
j'avais une bague à ces extraordinaires
et gérant d'un spectateur madiran jala
votre baguette du comment vous avez fait
pour la voir on voit tout beau théâtre
parce qu'on regarde attentivement on est
captivé par le dr
alors que cinéma ont subi un peu on vous
éclabousse avec toute sorte d'image des
plans de toutes les tailles
au théâtre il faut aller chercher
soi-même son son axe dans mes questions
un petit mot de christophe comment il
est comme étant en scène pourquoi vous
avez dit oui tout de suite
alors ils contestent une grande histoire
entre christophe et moi parce que je
n'avais jamais travaillé avec lui
tout de suite j'ai compris c'est un
crack ce type c'est un petit génie parce
qu'il a une sensibilité totalement cible
est totalement concentré sur les acteurs
et sur le texte qu'il est en train de
faire ça c'est assez formidable ne
s'éparpille pas son attention va
exactement là où on en a besoin et il
nous dit des choses qui sont
surprenantes c'est à dire que qu'elle
voit même qui nous nous décoiffe un peu
et nous les abeilles un peu il a
beaucoup de courage parce qu'il ose dire
aux acteurs des choses que d'autres
peut-être n'oserait pas dire des acteurs
chevronnés comme moi comme comme
nathalie ou comme bernard alane et il
est vraiment pertinents par exemple il
vous dit quoi ou qui auraient pu vous
décoiffer
franchement on a tous des petits défauts
on a tous des tic d'éthique de qui sont
des coquetteries en général d des
complaisances
et ça ça passe pas avec lui 1 c'est le
personnage le personnage le personnage
est donc on construit ensemble un
personnage c'est formidable vous savez
c'est passionnant parce que le public le
sent tout ce travail qui est fait ils ne
savent pas ils reçoivent une chose ils
se disent ah ça me plaît mais ils savent
pas que ça veut dire que derrière il ya
beaucoup de couches de travail de
intentions et je dirais de savoir faire
merci beaucoup merci